I don't know I guess that's something I
could say I'm pretty real like like
blunt I like flatness
Lex I'm fearing look at each other what
do you think I like your tattoos they're
very clean yeah I like your scorpions
thank you
universe
made her the ladies first bro
bro ladies first bro
that's hard that's a funny hey yo ladies
first bro hey Milady my [__] after you
homie yeah yeah that's how weird it is
bro
your mom [__]
[__]
I'm gonna give you a hard eight Hardy
what is a heart Avery only because I
don't know how old you are
I don't know I want to see her like 24
25 maybe four yeah are you 24 I'm 20. oh
[__]
how old are you
I don't care what nobody says when it
comes to guessing agents [__]
never missing yeah if you guys ever
catch me with an underrating woman it's
because I knew huh listen you understand
I never [__] up the ages
they're going to hold that [__] against
you so quick yeah yeah that's why I
gotta be careful if I do it I gotta be
shhh
I'm joking I'm just a joke Jesus Christ
is it look up it's a joke
we going on tour are we coming to cities
near you we want to see you
[__] face to face where you at
we gonna be doing shows awesome well
this summer we're doing three shows
we're doing Detroit Pittsburgh and
Washington DC but afterwards we were
going to England we're going to be going
all across America Asia so if you want
to get tickets make sure you guys go to
the website all right put your name so
we can email you as soon as those
tickets come out for your area we won't
bombard you with nothing else okay I
promise
um we want to see you guys at the shows
we meet us we have meet and greets we're
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna do
laughing so it's gonna be a good time uh
but we want to see you guys it's not bad
no I know it's not bad it's just you
can't drink
that's funny
it's funny because like people always
like they'll think I'm older and then
some people think I'm like younger like
it's weird I mean you definitely it's
like I have like nice skin but you have
like a really like manly build so I feel
like like you look pretty grown but also
I feel weird saying that you want to see
me grow yeah man uh step in my office
Predator yeah
foreign
[Music]
I'm telling you bro if this guy ends up
murdering people in the future I won't
be shot no yeah
nice to meet you nice to meet you what's
your name Leah Leah Leah unfair what is
it fair nice to meet you nice to meet
you I should probably start by saying
that like I am hard of hearing sounds
good I kind of am too because I used to
work at the airport really yeah I didn't
really like
have my hearing protection on all the
times dude you're also have hearing loss
not maybe I don't know maybe I'm always
like
yeah
yeah I do read lips and I feel like that
kind of like helps for intimacy
sometimes that's crazy so like how'd you
like pick that up like I don't know I
guess that's something I could say I'm
pretty real like like blunt I like
bluntness
I mean she was Reaching Forward too so I
can't be mad yeah you know both both of
them
okay why did you bet
you like me match you know what I mean
that that's okay I don't see that we
match you know I mean like
but we don't match
I look
you busted
yeah I can't see myself walking like
down the street with you
she likes blunt so he was blunt yeah hey
hey he said he was blunt she said she
like blunt then he proceeded to be blunt
so what's your name nice to meet you my
name is Jasmine Jasmine yeah Jasmine is
here in your type he's one of the types
he could be one of the types
okay oh no what's your name Jasmine Ben
fun fact about Ben he writes bad raps
emphasis on bad I will say that okay
would you like to hear yeah yeah sugar
off the top give me something to rap
about it's a button button yes the
button
just give me a second prepare because
there's no way this is gonna end well
Jasmine he's a husband he can rap but I
got you because I got you nothing
it was bad but all for the wrong reason
that you thought it was not for what you
thought it would be it was not even
because of Ben
um how's your week been what's been like
the Highlight it's it's my birthday week
really when's your birthday tomorrow
tomorrow mine is today
happy birthday thank you likewise are
you celebrating yeah so I'm doing this
I'm giving myself the gift of
opportunity to connect with people and
then tonight I'm having a birthday party
as well oh okay yeah
getting rejected multiple times it's
impossible oh that's cool because I'm
rejecting people
[Laughter]
make a wish somewhere else
surprise I just feel like this is one of
the worst ways to celebrate your
birthday it's just an ability to get
embarrassed in front of a lot of people
right what are you doing for yours I'm
gonna go to church and then I'll go have
lunch with my friends and then finish
the night off with my family so you go
to church you go every Easter I do I go
every Sunday do you
um I do not I'm Jewish so uh my dad's a
rabbi technically I'm Jesus Christ
I'm closer to Jesus than you girl what
your Jews I don't know Jesus Christ is
Jewish was he yes he was born Jewish
so technically he's more he's closer to
Jesus Christ than she is so I mean hi
but she's gonna Buzz him out I'd prefer
to tell you about the one true religion
Islam then talk about these heathens oh
yeah the one that you decided to dip off
out of so I said but I'm finding my way
back no you're not I'm just giving the
fan some hope they have no hope all
those people like oh I hope you find
your way back to Islam I hope you find
your way back to all I did like comments
and DMs like this oh yeah yeah there's
only some teach Hobbies thinking they're
gonna convert me
guys
I said hijabis oh I heard punjabis
sorry man I heard benchodies I've never
had a Punjabi DM me ever don't start no
yeah yeah yeah I said hey job if you let
girls you think men are wearing three
times but anyways
how about you I was exposed to a lot of
crazy things that maybe wouldn't be
normal and like
um someone who might not have been
raised Pentecostal oh Pentecost yeah
crazy things indeed I won't lie though
Pentecostal churches make the best
artists yes yeah all my favorite artists
especially from like r b Soul all that
all of them came from Pentecostal
churches yeah so they know how to praise
and make music yeah that's that's you
know that's a Baptist side yeah I love
your hair thank you oh my God I
appreciate it I grew it myself ask Jacob
what's the kinkiest thing he's ever done
oh yes what would that be I'm gonna be
honest I've been pretty vanilla yeah
your dad your dad's a rabbi you better
shut the [__] up yeah yeah your dad's a
rabbi like how vanilla like I've been
tied up before that's not that bad but
no but like it was yeah I was always
like by my dad
that would have been wow
that energy just wasn't
yeah I don't know it's just that I kept
looking at you and I just there was no
part of me that was like Chuck me Daddy
you know there's none of that so
nice nice to meet you
how are you we're good good fun fact
about Dylan oh he loves guns oh yeah
that's not a fun fact to know just to
like put the record out there not a
republican not a NRA member
what is it a gun license or whatever
that's called so fun fact you don't
actually need a gun license in
Washington state ah fun fact I don't
like that do you shoot animals oh [__]
no okay I'm a big history buff I've gone
from two from World War One wow that's
all service
thank you
[Music]
carry on
no you're the you like guns yeah
that's just typical person that doesn't
know nothing about guns but it just
knows what they know which is nothing
and it's again based himself on that
it's okay I mean the guys see like
there's something into antiques so like
of all the gun owners he seems like the
most old school one yeah the one that
you know out of all the guns the ones
that don't work yeah that's that's a
dangerous guy that's the dangerous guy
that's the danger right there I mean at
the end that you're entitled to be into
whatever you want to be into it's fine
that's fine and it's fine if you turn
off about one thing I get that I'm good
Brittany John John nice to meet you
too I like your necklaces in here so
you're into jewelry you're into
expression it looks like yes no I just
wear that [__] because it looked good
that's it calm down girl you're reading
too much into that let's go
so you you like you like
um you're like no calm down it's not
that I put that [__] because it looked
good but anyways you don't like
expressing yourself that's not what I
said you don't like expressing yourself
that's not what I said so what
would you say
I just see sometimes people read too
much into this well I'm asking you
sure you like expressing yourself
through sure
oh nice
he's waiting to do this
so you want to express yourself through
anger is that what's happening right now
the exactly yeah and I don't know why
when you do this post you have to like
lean yourself
yes yeah I hate this oh when they go so
oh guys so
that's the equivalent of rephrasing
everything you said and not saying
anything you said oh look at me
expressing myself
so I just like picking out unique things
that I like and going from there yeah I
like it she's so with him it's
disgusting yeah I like it you notice how
our boys got way softer yeah
yeah
so Brittany Loves R B music yes Loves R
B music it's his code for like she [__]
[__]
hi
yes I do button you you are correct okay
what's your favorite song right now
uh I wouldn't say it's like a new song
Jamie Foxx oh
um old school like Bobby Valentino
except Bobby Valentino
and Jamie Foxx
she got some weird r b takes no Bobby
Valentino is weird
slow down
I just wanna get to know you
don't turn around cause that pretty
little thing looks good to me ooh baby
slow down
yeah Bobby Valentino that's weird Jamie
Foxx that's weird too
if that's what your favorite song
involves favorites yeah I know but
people yeah that's like saying yo rap
music's my favorite oh who was that
white girl from Australia
Iggy Azalea come on don't know that's
weird if you were to say rap music is
your favorite they don't have a song
together
do that
yeah beep
2009 yeah beep beep you know they have
two songs Bobby Valentino has beep beep
and he has
like I got guy oh my god oh all right
Aaliyah what do you like
well mostly r b okay yeah yeah okay yeah
you're definitely gonna bust her out
once you said Bobby Valentino and Jamie
Foxx has her favorite that's a l I'm
sorry John is really kinky oh
oh Emily limits that I can't think of
almost it it depends not going into like
yeah pain and hitting I mean with the
right person in the situation
no there's limits I mean well not
painting well you know I would so so
y'all you just have to talk more about
your limits that's it carry on Hey
listen if she down for you she might be
open to anything it sounds like he's
really the extreme stuff so he might
find a match yeah when you're in the
moment yeah it changes a little bit oh
yeah yeah it's attracted to each other
yeah she's very pretty oh thank you
you're pretty too oh I'll take that
I'll take that
all this like oh you're pretty you're
pretty okay so dungeon
um I like your eyes
oh okay yeah yeah and I like your smile
too and like your jawline when you smile
like it's
it's like muscular oh really and that
sounds weird because it's your face
I got muscles on my face girl you can
sit on that [__] all day every day
I do like
like your energy like your
aura as you said yeah but you're fun
thank you I appreciate it
one more time
[Music]
it's been nice talking to you red button
well guess what I guess even old people
can find love wonderful
it's not even now
you don't even call the old yeah
that's why you didn't see you you'll see
but anyways anything else about this no
these are discusses because people are
in love no that's not love yeah that's
love oh you're nice of smiling oh my God
look at your cheekbones and I want you
do you want me yeah okay oh [__] it's
just like I don't know the progression
is
nice smile kinky this is a bit weird to
me a bit weird I'm not gonna lie but
anyways anything else
you're into jelly handcuffs take me
let's see what you guys think